a number like saying 24
okay
how do we
carry out the prime factorization of 24
what do we do we draw a particular kind
of diagram right what does it look like
it's we call it a factory good okay
so there's a few different ways you can
draw it
guys
then don't then don't make it worse
so how do i do
a prime factorization on this thing
what how do i how do i draw a factory
first step you guys know this
um
okay now two and twelve weren't the only
pairs right what else could i pick eight
yep
six and four what else
and three but they're all going to be
fine if we follow them down to the end
we'll get to the same thing
two what do i do with this
just bring it down again okay so i'm
gonna bring him down to the bottom when
i'm done okay i don't know how far it's
gonna go okay so but i can't factorize
him anymore because he's
he's primed good
12 not priced what would i do with it
then go up to two um down
okay
so good we're very good at this
now we're done because all of the things
on the ends of the branches they're all
prime okay so um as sharp suggested
before i'm going to bring this two down
to the bottom and this two down and now
let's get them
now we're done
okay
so what does it mean this means that
coming back to my original color okay we
can write 24
as
this here right 2
times 2 times 2
times 3. now you've already learned
index notation so we know a much more
concise succinct way to write this how
would we write it yeah uh 2 to the power
of 3
good
there you go and we do tend to i mean we
don't have to because multiplication you
can change the order around and that's
fine but we do like to put them in the
order of the size of the primes just
like we had on the top here right so
small parts first big primes later